[Music]
hi hi
who are you and how do you know each
other I'm Maddie I'm Carlos we work
together
yeah at a bar I bartend I guess I'm in
the kitchen and I also do counter I work
at the front desk and he's a massage
therapist
you were at the front desk and he's a
massage purpose
business in the front party in the bag
would you say that he massages your
front desk
so you're more than uh we're friends yes
you massages my friend
[Music]
what are the rules for hooking up with a
co-worker what are the rules to hook him
up with someone at work
don't don't next topic oh
I mean listen if we're being honest I
think it's gonna happen 40 of like
couples start at work okay it's like
it's crazy how high it is you're and it
makes sense you know you're there from
like morning till evening you're dressed
you've got your makeup whatever like and
you're around these people all the time
stands to reason you're probably gonna
want to [ __ ] one of them okay yeah very
reasonable bars it's exponentially High
restaurants and bars anywhere where
there's alcohol involved there's a lot
more [ __ ] involved can you guess why
inhibitions are lowered blame it on the
I
exactly okay enjoy your herpes so the
class is bound to happen when you work
at bars
I've noticed this
all my friends who worked at bars or
restaurants tell me they're [ __ ] one
of their co-workers they just always
ended up happening so
and if they're if your significant other
works at a bar restaurant they're
cheating on you
is that is that too far that's too
that's too much that's too far yeah
there's a lot of people with
insecurities right now yeah that's great
they're cheating on you that's great
foreign
a lot of people were like damn my
girlfriend's gonna bug me all day now
well you shouldn't have cheated on her
stupid yeah I feel like definitely to
not be like constantly talking about it
or making it a big thing right away
don't [ __ ] at work that's yeah oh you
went we already did that yeah yeah
well I mean I imagine you're closing the
bar he's cleaning the kitchen
there's a spill on Iowa
Bar and Kitchen and you have aisles in
your bar
I know there's aisles in the kitchen
there's no aisles in the kitchen there's
one aisle there's the island in the
middle right where all the stuff is and
then you walk around in circle those are
aisles no that's one eye and that's in
the middle well it depends on your
kitchen my kitchen had two eyes
white kitchen
the kitchen had two aisles what kitchen
what do you want kitchen of where
a kitchen in your head the one that you
imagine that never happened I never
existed
and it has
thank you
they had numbers it had it had it had
numbers
were you calling me out like damn this
[ __ ] knows how do you find out my
body's betraying me because I worked in
kitchen what the [ __ ] you mean
you know what energy I came with you
with uh yeah I got a girlfriend oh she
goes to another school you wouldn't know
her
what's cool oh you wouldn't know it it's
across town oh I got my sister going to
that school too what's her name uh she's
an escape student she just arrived last
year her name starts with a g what is it
you guessed it if you know you know
[Laughter]
and my butthole exploded
laughs
remember when [ __ ] would lie behind
his girlfriends that [ __ ] was deadly bro
back then social media wasn't a thing so
you could lie and try to get away with
it no you couldn't you just couldn't
everybody [ __ ] really try to
lie yeah
she's older she goes to another school
what school yeah yeah so I'm about oh
yeah that's cool cool when my sister
goes there let's go meet her right yeah
it was the most inappropriate time I
made you horny at work I feel like it's
the other way around though like I would
do it to them I would like pull them
pull them aside to like make out with
them or
you got time
oh okay maybe this person's gender
neutral so that's why they keep saying
them
yeah whatever I don't care okay I was
confused oh okay yeah I didn't know
what's going on okay my bad sorry
I'm not used to hearing people actually
say that a lot I've never actually heard
someone say them
because like they're pointing to the
other person
that's the topic for a different day
I think that happened like once
they went up to your room after a
massage you had just had a client and we
I like closed the door
[Laughter]
and it got like just so just a little
bit risky I was definitely turned on I
know exactly what you're talking about
but we cut it out
trying to make a pizza and you started
texting all these
nasty things but we had he's having
flashbacks
good and I was making pizza
and
you started to text all these uh
I feel like making pizzas are very like
flowery process right it's a doughy
process yeah flour right how do you just
grab your phone in the middle of making
a pizza and be like
yeah trying to get me going and you did
you did and like it was like super busy
and my lurches like so I just started
[ __ ] the pizza
[Laughter]
you want some fishes
hahaha
what's she doing rolling that dough
yeah if you could sleep with anyone else
at work who would it be
smart answer
oh no name three things you hate about
your boss I don't know what it is when a
[ __ ] looks like a librarian that [ __ ]
turns me on yeah
something about books and old long
skirts it's not books what is it
supposed to hush at a library you want
to make us cream
no oh okay no it's not that it's the
books you look at books and you're like
I want to put my dick in books no no no
it's about the setting there's something
about the long skirt you know the long
ass big ass skirt from like medieval
times something about hiking that [ __ ]
up and be like you winch that you know
and you know what's good what about
Library no they're aisles there
facts facts my my library only had one
album this is like a long haul what
library library
my body
nah man I don't know what it is like a
woman I know I know you mediocre and she
looked like a librarian she'd go up two
points conquer yeah and if a girl like
uh ass girl like yo you're a librarian
and they're like no I'm like [ __ ] how
many books you got if you got more than
10 you qualify yeah you're a gliberian
and and and if they say no I'm like
[ __ ] just lie to me so I can get hard
again you get what I'm saying just make
it happen
do you guys know that being the library
requires a [ __ ] degree I just thought
you had to put books on the [ __ ]
shelf no these people have to get
degrees
and intense ones I I don't know I don't
know about that that's how you know I've
dated Librarians okay
the Morgan now if one of us were to get
a raise for great sex who should it be I
feel like I'm getting the race
what do you thinking to get a raise huh
I brought the toys in that's why I was
gonna raise that is definitely right
that's what I would agree I introduced
the toys I wasn't really into toys until
until I met her it's kind of fun yeah
yeah for sure
um
okay
what this is pure classy so audience you
guys are watching right now you can fill
me in
personally yeah I just do the toys for
the ladies
I don't give a [ __ ] now guys out there
when toys get brought out does that make
it more enjoyable for you
I want you guys to let me know in the
comments below because my experience is
that toys are for women most of the time
um yes I know there are a array of toys
for men but uh more than that it's like
whenever you're doing a roof you know
over the like you know where the roof
you're building a roof or you're
repairing a roof for your ladies uh
your lady's uh house uh you could use a
hammer and you know Hammer those
shingles or you could use
a power armor you know what I mean I
mean it is for my wife but it makes the
job easier so it's good for me is
because I finished it earlier do you
believe everybody's satisfied do you
believe that menus toys is nearly as
much as women do no okay
no I would argue that the vast majority
of men don't use toys or don't care for
toys and the vast majority of men who do
use toys do it initially for the women
um because I am a conversation I someone
agree yeah but I I don't know I would
something I I could be wrong so let me
know in the comments if you're one of
these dudes who like butt plugs and all
this other stuff I would somewhat agree
but
there's definitely some guys out there
if we end things who's going to have the
hardest time with it
you
sure
probably yeah
yeah as fast as I connect with somebody
if it doesn't work out I'm just as fast
just to just drop it and I lose all
emotions and all the type of attachments
to it yeah and girls I hate that [ __ ]
what oh the fact that you could just
walk away
it means you never really cared and none
of it was ever really real that's right
that's what they think yeah
yeah good because they don't really see
it as a form of uh way to protect
yourself did you see yet like you were
not engaged you were not you didn't you
didn't care that's why it's so easy for
you it's not it doesn't work like that
but sometime is really just a form of
protection it's easier for me like that
to just reject everything and just
thought it out the [ __ ] window but
they don't yeah they don't get that
which I understand it is exclusive super
exclusive it's not a reason yeah like
over the weekend actually it was my
first birthday and then I'm like what
are we doing like we're into each other
super hard why don't we just make this
official and then she was like say it
yes
yeah she did that she did exactly that
she did it right there she [ __ ] did
it there hey yeah I've been thinking
about that [ __ ] yeah
the GC is falling in love
good this I'm happy so yeah I I
definitely can
[Laughter]
yeah
it was whatever he wasn't trying to be
condescending
I told you [ __ ] when we say
something sweet one of the things we
hate the [ __ ] most hearing is oh
that's cute that's cute oh man didn't I
say on that [ __ ] podcast
yeah we were talking about vulnerability
with me and the dudes yeah and I was
just talking one of them said uh
vulnerable uh what is it vulnerability
is a new sexy yeah and I was like no
don't do that don't don't make a slogan
out of like with men like well guys your
vulnerability is so sexy it's cute it's
just like we don't like that [ __ ] no
no we don't like we just don't I don't I
can't explain it I don't have no size to
it one of the worst things you could do
I just was like some guy's like oh I
really I'm really into you oh that's
cute
oh
oh hey man I'm
oh no I just uh
I really
I've come to terms of the fact that I
care about you
oh
bro I got mad
I actually got mad and I knew you were
gonna do it
how visceral it is
Ah that's cute oh
that's not good that's not good don't do
it don't do it I get where he's coming
from no don't do it I feel like we
connected really well I really enjoy
spending my time with you like that
energy is there for sure I feel like I'm
probably blushing so hard right now
because you're white white yeah you're
too pale okay listen Twilight okay you
not ever gonna blush okay Edward
[Laughter]
how was that sometimes uncomfortable but
it's cool would you play this with your
other co-workers okay yeah we're gonna
have a co-worker orgy we've already
talked he's not gonna be down with that
unless the other person unless the other
person he wants to [ __ ] is going to be
there Hey listen I'm gonna tell you guys
this I'm gonna tell you guys not to [ __ ]
your co-workers because you're gonna do
it anyways okay people when they get
horny or they get Love Lies they're
gonna do it so you can do it live your
best lives go make your mistakes
enjoy yourselves get fired whatever it
happens get your herpes good luck oh and
if your co-worker works at a bar in a
restaurant they're cheating